this is a production of Cornell
University
okay and today I'd like to show you the
progress that we're making in the swirls
lab to map and identify a gene that
influences kernel weight and morphology
and also proposed a novel mechanism and
strategy for fine mapping genes that can
produce potentially accelerate that
process and their integration into
breeding germ plasm
so traditionally breeders have been
limited by the rate and positioning of
crossovers in their mapping of QTL or
quantitative trait loci and this is
especially true for a quantitative trait
like grain yields grain yield is a
balancing act between the spikes per
area the kernels per spike and the
weight per kernel and it's not
surprising but for a quantitative trait
like grain yield
there have been genetic associations
with grain yield components on every
weak chromosome these grain yield
components are often negatively
correlated due to energy constraints for
the plant and we also has a very large
and polyploid genome and due to the
limiting rate and positioning of
crossovers few studies to date have
fully characterized and deployed causal
genes and thesaurus lab strategy that
we're taking is a reductionist approach
considering the independent action of
individual yield components and by
better understanding the genes
underlying yield components we can
position ourselves to better understand
how they collect the impact finally
yields and today I'd like to take the
time to talk about the importance of
kernel weight kernel weight is
influenced primarily by grain filling
characteristics such as how long plant
is a photosynthetically active in the
field as well as the physical parameters
of the kernels such as their length or
width which are under independent action
in wheat and there's been a variety of
mechanisms that have been attributed to
increasing grain weight but often it has
to do with an increase in cell size or
cell number and when releasing a new
variety of wheat it's really important
to consider grain weight because the
weight can one influence the number of
kernels it takes to fill a bushel which
affects a farmers bottom economic line
as well as the shape can influence the
milling efficiency of the grain
affecting whether the right value chain
accepts your variety so in the soils of
working with a by parental wheat
population synthetic w7 984 by a pata
m85 and we've identified a QTL that
influences grain weight via an increase
in grain widths on chromosome five a due
to the APOD appearance alleles and to
increase our genetic resolution of this
trait we've developed heterogeneous
inbred families or hits um and if is
very useful because you minimize the
noise in the background genome well
increasing resolution of your traits we
do this by selecting from a very inbred
plant already in this case at an f6
stage has a very homogeneous and
homozygous background genome but is
selected because it's heterozygous
across the QTL region we've been
advancing single plants sense that of
six plant that have there again a very
homogeneous background genome but
differences in crossovers across the QTL
or maintain hetero zygosity giving us
high confidence that we can associate
the phenotypes we see with the genotypes
if we zoom in closer on this QTL region
on the x-axis is the LOD scores which is
just the significance of association
between a snip and a phenotype for the
site your environments and on the y-axis
is that chromosome five a is 350 to 450
mega base pairs we have two really
significant peaks in association with
kernel width and tkw thousand kernel
weight which is our industry standard
measurement for kernel weight and these
two peaks could be due to two causal
variants but it could also be due to
linkage which I'll get into next so
there's a lot to see on this slide but
I'll walk you through it on the left
hand side is an info graphic of the
chromosome at our cutie olive region
with the most predictive snips for the
key TL to Peaks highlighted in red and
the different rows represent different
if gene o types that share the same
genotype across the region of
significance and a pata alleles are
represented in black boxes and synthetic
alleles are represented in the white
boxes and first I'll draw your attention
to that 341 point 5 mega base pairs snip
the way you'll continue to read this is
across to the right hand side the dist
ocean of the phenotypes associated with
hits that have that genotype and the
different rows or hip groups as I
mentioned represent the different plants
that share that genotype we see it the
first QTL peak at three hundred forty
one point five mega base bears a really
consistent association between the
presence of the oh pata allele and
larger thousand kernel weight phenotypes
and the presence of the synthetic allele
and smaller thousand kernel weight
phenotypes
if you move across and look at that
second QTL peak with the markers from
three hundred seventy eight to three
hundred eighty-five mega base pairs
there's less consistent association
between which parent is associated with
a greater that wasn't kernel eight which
is problematic for our fide mapping so
we could go with the story that there's
two causal variants represented by these
red asterisks that are notably though
every half plant that has the red
asterisks has the same a pata allele
under both peaks are the same synthetic
alleles under both peaks so they're
technically there could be linked the
second option is a story that's told by
two hip groups highlighted in green one
group one has the pata allele under that
first peak which we know is associated
with a greater that was in kernel weight
and then the synthetic allele under the
second peak which we would expect to
have a smaller thousand kernel weight
but we see if you know typically a
thousand kernel weight that's similar to
the groups that have a pata under both
Peaks same for group eight synthetic
allele under the first peak we'd expect
a smaller phenotype Oh Pato allele under
the second peak but we get a more of a
synthetic like phenotype for groups that
have synthetic under both peaks now we
can look across online references and
gene annotations and previous existing
expression studies to narrow our
candidate gene list but it's going to
require our own gene expression study to
confidently understand the interaction
between the two peaks so the summer I
conducted a day's post in thesis grain
morphology test which is basically
tracking grain development over time to
better understand when this difference
in kernel width and weight is expressed
and I worked with ten different if
genotypes that either had the positive
or negative causal variant and tag those
all the spikes that were included in
this experiment and the Assessor zero
days post in thesis
and then return to the field at their
respective 4:10 16 and 22 days to
measure the developing grain and I
worked with to replicate subhead rows
for every genotype and we took ten
spikes for every samples time point and
then ten kernels were taken from the
spike specifically at the centre where
they're pollinated first and measured
their wets there with the fresh and dry
weight and you can see here on the
x-axis the day's post in thesis starting
at zero out to 22 for our last time
point and their respective phenotype on
the y-axis here kernel width and the
plants that have the positive causal
variant are represented in dark blue and
have plants with negative causal variant
are an aqua you can see that as the
grain development progresses we have a
spread in those phenotypes for the two
genotypes same for fresh weight which we
know is highly correlated with our
kernel width in this population and it
persists when the kernels are dried
clearly something is going on in our
population in Ithaca New York during 10
to 16 days both post and thesis that's
driving this difference in phenotype far
too positive and not negative causal
variant genotypes giving us a really
high confidence window of when we need
to do our grain tissue sampling for gene
expression and is also worth noting that
these plants have no difference in grain
filtration suggesting that the gene was
probably going to influence cell
division rates rather than cell duration
division of so duration of cell division
if we return to this infographic though
if we wanted to confidently narrow our
candidate gene list it would require a
crossover event between the QTL Peaks
are within them which we know is quite
resource intensive and time intensive
and our attention as such has turned to
genome editing strategies it's a
long-standing goal of breeders in
Genesis to manipulate a combination and
crossover frequency and with the advent
of DNA targeting tools this is becoming
increasingly applicable where terming
this methodology it controlled the
combination and I think it's incredibly
fascinating we should be able to tether
a deactivated caste 9 to spo11 which is
a protein that catalyzes double-stranded
breaks during meiosis guitar
those double-stranded breaks in a
heterozygous background of our QTL
though some of those double-stranded
breaks will be repaired as a crossover
and we can recreate a fine wrapping
population or develop a new fine
wrapping population with far fewer
plants and far fewer generations I'm in
the early stages of developing the
protocols for targeted or guided
recombination controlled recombination
in wheat but I'm motivated by the many
applications we see across the breeding
cycle first in pre breeding we've
already discussed the importance and
accelerating gene identification but
this can also be useful for creating
finer introgression x' with wild germ
plasm parent selection is a critical
decision for breeders and controlled
recombination can help with create
identifying optimal haplotypes and
introducing those into the breeding germ
plasm different controlled recombination
strategies will have different outcomes
of efficiency for crossovers whether
you're knocking out a crossover
suppressor gene or targeting
double-stranded breaks where you're
interested in getting a crossover so the
reader can then identify optimal
crossovers as well as select for null
suck organs for your genome editing
constructs and then with a controlled
recombination and better identification
of the genes that we want to be
introducing into our germ plasm we can
more rapidly improve existing leap
varieties the next steps of this
research are of course to validate and
characterize the QTL on chromosome 5a
and we can do this with a gene
expression study to better understand
also what's going on with the two peaks
as well as knockout and knockin the
genes that we identified to be our
causal variant our first attempt at
controlled recombination in wheat will
be to do a proof of principle study and
regenerate at the fine mapping
populations for this QTL with fewer
individuals and generations and the
ultimate goal of this research is to
implement the beneficial alleles for
yield components in elite varieties as
well as our breeding germ plasm
that I would like to thank the many
individuals who helped make this
research possible and I'd be happy to
answer any questions yeah we had time
for a few questions so yes the question
was if we've looked into epistasis
between the two key GL Peaks that's a
great question
this was a recent discovery of the key
TTT a week so that's something that's on
our to-do list Yannick I guess kind of
along those same lines it would be
interesting if you have I mean I don't
know justjust he it might be interesting
if there was an interaction and that
interaction was actually like a protein
in an activator right so you may just
you know might be a good idea to think
about not just looking for teens - yeah
I don't think the question was a
proposal that maybe there's something
beyond just two genes in this region and
they have an interaction and we need to
keep an open mind about what might be
going on because I'm it's pretty
interesting that we saw two peaks once
we got a better recombination event that
helped us zoom in any other questions we
have time for yes Kevin so when I look
at at least within our synthetic apado
population we only get significance for
this trait on chromosome 5 I you don't
see it on the beer the D but when we
look you know I like gene annotations
they do have homologous copies on the
other chromosome so we will have to pay
attention with our sequencing of those
regions to just make sure we're
targeting like appropriate Pam sites
yeah yeah it's primary so the seminal
studies are really in yeast it has had
recent success in tomato and
actually targeting somatic cells and
that was probably the most breeding
applied a success because they were
targeting a color for fruit or fruit
color gene and that's something we'd be
interested in as breeders a lot of the
other studies though are more trying to
translate recombination in yeast
Arabidopsis to crop species so actually
wrote a review of this it's in peer
review with trends and plant sciences so
keep an eye out and there'll be a lot of
influence that yeah thank you thank you
all right thanks everybody around
applause this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu